yeah I'm early [__] hey guess who's not
late today feels good man
how early gang but you weren't expecting
that [__] yeah [__] beach it thank
you thank you
finished oh my [__] quick today got my
workout I hope feels good I'm channel
all that Abbi energy so a reason I
starting early so if you're watching
this offline just cut forward because I
want to spend trying to figure out why I
can't get headphones working in the
controller everyone kept saying cringe
Phillies can't figure it out in the
comments so here I am I'm gonna [__]
figure it out my theory is that if I put
headphones through their controller then
you guys will not be able to hear the
game that's what I think is gonna happen
but if I'm wrong that would be very
convenient alright so let's walk me
through this I could have done this solo
but now I can blame it on you guys if it
doesn't work so what should I put the
settings on these hensel's are a bit
weird because they have a lot of [__]
center
you need to plug them in and then change
the settings okay they're plugged in oh
my god okay can you guys still hear it
cuz I hear it let me check the levels
see you guys aren't hearing it now told
you [__] I was right all along
[__] got him yeah I hear it [__] you
guys think you're so [__] smart don't
you but you're not you're so wrong so
many times I have to be make a conscious
choice to be like no they don't know
what the [__] they're talking about
Felix I was right say it apologize
apologize I want a written essay oh how
wrong you were
I called it small brain say you have
small brain and then I thought then I
forget yeah it doesn't let you do it
even if I plugged in my USB version it
still doesn't do it because I try that
before is there any other way to do it
[Music]
I know you can hear it now cuz I
unplugged it dumbasses man today
we're finishing a bee-sh maybe Dingley
dag is there delay with my boys
is there any issues before we get
started
[Music]
my voice is low put the microphone in
water I'll turn up my mic a little bit
see how that doesn't I looked at
yesterday's live stream and it was
pretty pretty decent levels I would say
seemed alright some parts it was way off
though alright I'll do this I'll
increase one all less than a decibel
that should be a little more yeah who's
ready to finish his [__] look I have
got a war should we play that instead
[Music]
here we are I just really want to see
how this game ends really badly and the
game is so goddamn pretty I look forward
to playing just the thing also that that
[__] explosion from yesterday when I
blew up that guy's legs that was such a
funny moment I want to try and do more
[__] like that in the game
but you know I want to play as Ellie
again you see explosive arrows break
down where were they taking the kids
shelters everywhere
oh there Karen's a kids
just checking to have the right
microphone
they took the gates Karen
they look so cozy this really feels like
outlast apparently there's a new outlast
revealed called really blurb that or
something I didn't know that
oh my god it's true a raccoon
the [__] wrong with these people you
can't just put raccoon on walls ah you
went too far last of us apparently you
can hold down triangle and loot
everything at the same time I was just
about to say that and it worked but you
can't just do doo look the graphics are
so good in Last of Us look guys I'm
joking but for real what did they do to
your raccoon the [__] did they do to you
it's not fair I don't like this
can't just do raccoons like this and
expect me to be okay with it
was it raining inside the house shitty
buildings they built huh all right we
have upgraded a line stability on this
bad boy
put raccoon in rice that'll do that'll
do so I was like you guys tell me what a
sharp gray because I'm not sure at this
point stabilized El Diablo
wait for the burst fire
I never have much ammo I don't really
see the point
let stability for this [__] 25% and 35%
that's a big upgrade
upgrade the aka I don't have an 8k what
are you talking about we're still
looking for the inking Oh for [__]
sake I keep forgetting that they always
have stuff next day please for the love
of God same raccoon see how I felt like
we were kind of missing a goal in this
game but now I feel like I have won how
you guys doing today on this beautiful
Saturday alright we'll sell through this
entire mission or at least I'll pretend
to do that and then I'll just end up
killing everyone because that's what
I've been doing this entire don't
brother they got torches and [__] kind
of want to check this out the [__] kind
of building is this okay fine
brother they got Tomatoes maybe I
shouldn't kill them this is really like
outlast
I mean look up
bro they got potatoes check cept the
guys crying and happiness
alright let's take these guys out
whoops gonna go behind the house no dude
you're totally seen
okay
got one guy in the house let's wait for
the right time
Abia stam Oh
this is why I hate stuffing my god you
have to wait okay he's coming slowly yes
yeah look over there oh good job and
then he turned and now we kill and now
your day I hope you enjoyed them
please don't see me while I kill this
man hey mo
[__] Yoink God I wish I knew about
the hole down triangle thing sooner
we're pretty good on shipment
how did he not see that body should we
try and shoot this [__] [__] how many
hours left on a bee everyone spread out
no they didn't what are you talking
about nice reaction skills [__] 7 Abby
never ends Abby continues in your life
now [__] I should have shot I pushed it
out oh god okay so now they take
headshots
what the [__] that's so dumb come out
[__] [__]
stop it stop part of the playing guys
it's part of the play it's part of the
plan
it's part of the plan it's all part of
the plan I meant to do that
I shot her in the [__] head you saw
that especially like you're sure you
wearing a helmet or something right
you're right that is a huge threat all
right you ready for this
how do you survive that bomb do what
they got a sick gold that's sick
all right pretty good style for mission
here I like that align remember when I
said it we're good on ammo
I remember [__] how'd I miss that
sneak hundred thanks guys
it's more fun killing them oh [__]
they didn't see me didn't see me but
here I am
brick master 64 what was that
might go through some [__]
sniping [__] yeah big shoot them in the
head then shape oh you're trying don't
you don't shoot I'm Swedish I'm Swedish
no she missing us speaking Swedish that
was rough unbelievable
well they give you arrows so you can
sell through this oh nice you got pills
that's someone gonna die don't shoot
Swedish bang bang bang we all know it
dressed in Swedish hey this guy's got a
lot of ammo
let's have a look at what we did
let's put a smile on that face what is
that oh my god we hit all of them in the
pooper upin joopa the tongue was fine
shot him in the mouth with the tongue
made it
it's protein nuts ow
strong like a bee oh this looks like it
okay
roasted ear limbs
it's here come on Steve rating Village
Colorado
this way
damn we're full I'm didn't happen no
they got kids
ah ah stop this spin then wake up [__]
these people
maxed-out [__]
I'm almost done
if in the chat first man right
can you kill these
you can't why not
they make you kill a dog we're [__]
goats
unbelievable use the pipe bomb does that
work oh my god I should try that she
look so young
how do you know that
thank you
here
yara i I never should have
did the mom drop any allude any nice
loot no nothing
what's the point
fine I'm gonna drop epic loot that's all
I know that's all I'm saying
she's running to work through me he's re
my baby
where's Hazen
all right thundersnow matter
why I'm eating I'm almost done
goddamnit
we're in that part of the game huh
they just give you so much [__] more
pipe bombs more ammo I like this gun too
much come have to do it yeah sweet [__]
they're spicy
alright let's go
all right
healthy nuts good sang num-num sorry I
know it's really loud baby shark gives
me strength but a he tweets his own
you know everyone is different you're
eating in this allowed I couldn't even
oh okay well that's good
chewing gum
so taking no no we're looking for over
right just mind remember what we're
doing
brother found Levi what's the point now
nice one a be part 69 thousand years
hell yeah
alright I guess I stopped
sorry game I'm going to escape why don't
we go back the way I came all you did
straight why David's chillin did they
drop any loot
yeah can we afford another upgrade
already they gave us so much [__] we
came hostage Moomin speed if we kill
them quicker I would go for it otherwise
pipe bomb I'm going for the explosions
more fun
goddamned see you know it said towards
the end of a bee because they're giving
us so much [__] now I'm they're looking
for loot still sorry
Oh
waiting for me thanks guys
almost done with a B feel this good man
there's a minigun in the fridge I'll get
it next time today is a good thing just
keep going
alright I'll keep going in time I want
to look for Luke but I'll keep going hey
don't break his [__] arm
you no need to break his arm
the hell are you doing I need you to
hear me out
what's that behind you
Yara dying he saved my life are you
saying my the way we'll deal with you
back home he's not one of them please
Eddie move goddamn it he's just a kid
run child to get away from that scar one
really gonna shoot me no [__] moving
you're a dime No oh now she Davis oh oh
whoa nice Yara
what a heroic BAFTA first jolt I like
that you're my people wait what
we're gonna have to fight to get out of
this okay and then I need you to show us
to those boats we don't we don't know if
she's your ax is dead for real though
[Music]
god the game just [__] showers you
with items now
so this is the last of us huh Abby
becomes Joel Levi becomes Ellie it is
what it is
[__] I'm full
you don't hit the bun then we look up
first rule of us with us you stuck
you look up you stuck you look up there
it is
every puzzle in last of us look up
which gun should I have a oh [__]
I was trying to sell fear
they saw me ride away ha
how are you not dead
oh [__] don't hit me hey guys the bottle
I'm almost I deserve to die the [__] did
Levi do
my bad and that's how the game ends I'm
never ready for that the self is like oh
I'm supposed to stop oh cool see that's
more like it
this guy's coming out first
hello
[Music]
come on you don't want to show yourself
then put it is it going down it's going
down
[__] [__] I want to hit artists
did you find her you'll never find me
[__] [__] artists one more come on
we just knock her out hello there's
always more of them I never know where
the [__] they're shooting from because I
can't hear oh yeah there's one up there
wasn't it
present Oh
oh yes no leg gang no leg game this is
so sad
the fight bugs are the best
snip-snip
[__] there's one they got me [__] give
me craft anymore
I'll up guys I'm looking for Luke
might be good time to use this
[__] are they you'll never find me
there's one guy far away me something
white
what happened there
hello
shoot him in the head there's more for
fun sake where are they where bish where
there ya hump me down please show me
your pity
how you doing there Paul what you still
with me okay let's get to me accent hey
it's chill here homie let your stealth
area hold on a sec
yeah give me more loot on the roof okay
I'll check it really quick this is the
most fun gameplay I love this [__] I
missed a Frick scene excuse me how
Misaka that is not too smooth
in the ad
let's make some more pipe bombs one you
had to put one minute I'm going to the
rope
I mean there was loot on this route oh
there is yeah this is a break isn't it
this is a break
a bottle I'll take it
all right we're done
something here
I have to lose otherwise I can't make a
Malone [__] so can't make animal
you still have a flamethrower I forgot
about that full ammo
cover me
what's up
don't to Bahamas sweets I'm notorious
for lady Oh can't help it you guys made
me this way
remember when you bully me into looting
more huh remember Jana died
yeah should I give a summary for people
that didn't watch the last episode sure
with that which I think it's fair there
was a second scene that was an aquarium
[Music]
ooh
before we yeah sweet I like the crossbow
I like this one
now we can upgrade yar I went to Bahamas
- fine tempting
yes it's nap time
Spanish guy went to Bahamas nor I went
to Bahamas dog went to Bahamas
where else went to Bahamas
yeah they got an apple Wow
oh wait it's Barney where the boats Joel
went the Bahamas of course he was one of
the first eugene went to Bahamas it's a
good place let's get down there
it's a pretty happy game people just
follow their dreams they go to Bahamas
I'm not shooting me are they nope okay
so they haven't seen me yet I'll use
this to my advantage
sneaking there definitely shooting okay
they see how they haven't cool pocket
can't see is that his head oh my god can
you imagine being him does that apply
maybe I should be ignored
we're just sneaking it out you know any
more of them nope
surprise [__] oh wait
she was looking away I was like oh did
they see some Isles don't run it we'll
only pain more all right she then see
how I shot her they all did shooting oh
you gonna show yourself
shoot the tip over Hannah [__] sake
all right we got her I got her shot him
in the crossbow that was sweet
I think I don't think I'm supposed to I
don't think I'm supposed to be here this
is like a run-through
run
I don't know where to all right first
one speed um pom pom pom pom pom pom
para Bubba baby shark shark baby sugar
lemon baby shark shark baby sharks baby
baby shower baby baby
where am I supposed to go okay horses
hey guys oh my me alright oh my me let's
go
and up my yard again
oh yeah I got him
well actually I
bottom let's get these guys yeah we
should probably shouldn't run through
the fire but you know this is happening
oh god here we go we're fine
Jurgen hundred-percent armor 1000% armor
[Music]
don't shoot the horse [__] a chocolate
work sorry
don't shoot the horse don't shoot the
horse okay we're not shooting noises
we're just shooting the same like
this is a really cool part stop here off
here
damn what an epic moment
uragan badass mm yet again no cup
calling me horse
excuse me it's not that boards I look at
dogs
all right let's delve through this area
I'm kind of a stealth expert so I think
they want me to use the shotgun
Hey look the horse didn't bite maybe
game not so bad after all
all of them stop moving
thank you sure run through this just run
out a Medici better guys don't mind me
don't mind me I'm just chillin I'm just
chillin I probably should have good guys
don't mind I'm almost there
one more shot mundane [__] anyway I
should have healed before I went in
isn't this a time to just go all out and
just like keep shooting I feel like I'm
wasting it by running yeah I'll just all
this waste as much time
fun shoot
they don't even know I'm here
I guess we can run this sign now wait
there was a memo on the truck wasn't it
they wanted me to use the shot and it's
so obvious all this these that Beach let
me reload it no
in ekran tomorrow
how are we doing in here boys
what the [__]
[__] killing machine
one left
you were supposed to die what was the
guy behind me Levi if you want to get
this guy I'm okay with it
did he sing Levi got
you shouldn't mean Oh
damnit
okay out in the open
are you winning parrots
I'm winning well that was cool I send
all those people to Bahamas
[Music]
this is safe
get out of here why we're just entering
come on okay so maybe not that way
what do you mean it's fine
all right let's go through you
that's safe I can go under here
Abbey went to Bahamas it's hot this year
Oh No
now lad
you have guns and I know the topic okay
all right so I
way weighing is just doing the one swing
punish wow that hurt
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a bit rude
this is a really cool part I don't know
who it is it I don't know why we're
fighting but it's cool all the sudden my
sickle last very long
[Applause]
finish shame no levites gonna save us
right I need your Bahamas okay you
changed my mind
oh yeah bad
to the mouth that would have been a dope
scar kind of wish they would live to be
honest yeah all right so no gun now see
I told you it was worth it shooting all
those I knew but it was like one of
those
moment go all out [__] it's so loud now
I'm sorry
did you even hear me can you hear me can
you hear me hello they don't listen
I have personally
damn a lot about hummus boys
[Applause]
don't shoot alright cool we did it that
was a cool mission I like that that was
really fun
[Music]
send a lot of people to Bahamas for free
here I guess I be learned the lesson
that revenge bang just a little too late
this is like an emotional Family Guy a
piss broad we're almost done with a bee
I can't believe it we spear and I [__]
lady maternal looks like a fun game
not yet how much more how how is there
more how
let's get out of me yeah
I need a gun
don't need a gun my oh my gun all right
we had something in our back pocket to
open lock doors all this time okay
Oh No
[Music]
Ella's been here
listen I didn't want to do it either
there was literally no option but to
kill the [__] dog I can't believe it
baby shark so she killed Owen and
what's-her-name
Frank regulating we're gonna find them
bye-bye in Bahamas right now right dog
went to Bahamas everybody just chilling
in the hummus with some [__] llamas
Mel oh [__] she was pregnant I got about
that Ellie killed pregnant lady well I
guess she didn't care about the baby so
so [__] that it's getting so dark look
at that Andy you lost everyone yeah
just water really it should have been
pure protein coming out of there and you
got damn knowing I should have been
zebra meat coming out man do I feel bad
now
trust me play new McDonald yes the map
is back
[__] yeah hell yeah I've been waiting
for the man finally
yes map is the best character of the
game
[Music]
she puked a few Oh are we done we don't
we're done with Abby Dabba Dabba Dabba
Dabba done with Abby no all right
there's more gosh I wish the order of
the game was different so much it could
have been a really good game
still with me love
keep looking
but you need to be open-minded about the
game you just don't get it
okay well you should be open-minded I
don't like it
geez what do I get in look up rule of
law service
all right let's send Elly to Bahamas I'm
just my mind has been changed we're
gonna kill Ellie now oh my god what if
they make you fight Ellie how much more
overplaying fine the LED that did it the
neckline the landed hey Ellie I'm here
shoot me how do I help Ellie let's make
it as much noise as possible I'm here
shoot don't upgrade the gun
Leah went to Bahamas oh yeah hey yeah
I'm here
shoot Danny should we finish all our
ammo you can't
[Laughter]
hey guys it's me
Abbi I'm being controlled by someone
that doesn't like me
did someone say gold yeah I know I know
it's told me first but then la comes in
I said back up turn around you're making
a big mistake
love keep your bow honey get on the
ground you kill me like a coward oh my
gosh you had a [__] gun she could
have shot her as soon as she kicked him
and he was up she was open I can push
the Ellie goddamnit I know why you
killed y'all he did what he did to save
me there is no cure because of me I am
the one that you want I'll just let him
go
you killed my friends Thank You Sierra
appreciate you arrow to the knee meal Oh
Tom no I'm not gonna [__] kill Ellie
stay here watch the exits don't let her
leave right F in the chat with Tommy
we should check if he's safe I'll open
this door alright shoot me shoot me I'm
free
no and okay we're good
Ellie's safe don't worry
yeah I get that page here and do it do
it do it do it yeah all right game over
Ella got her revenge cool
good game what do you mean don't attack
le head-on I understand what was the
point
all right sorry for trolling I'll just
play it's just weird
this is I am NOT failing this at all
really le you're that dumb yeah I just
feel good Bahamas is overbooked [__]
but I dodge them I'm not supposed to go
at her in some cases running away is
your only choice okay well my Ben thing
being me me me me me me me me me me mung
bean ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba baby baby baby
beep beep you'll never find me where do
I go hey Ellie
we can work this out
let's just talk this out let's play
around a golf I mean we could play
tennis tennis come on let's talk about
this
let's go I spoke go to Bahamas I was
supposed to sneak up on her where the
[__] did she go though I don't know
where she is nauseous
you don't see me but here I am yes I
should be you're the best yeah back up
here
Bing mom la kill me I'm behind you is
that what I was that was it that was all
I has to do an a/b protein very high
protein snack one dose
sorry Ellie I don't like this either
this is so strange
rush snack
not gonna get away you see here it let's
throw it at her sorry Ellie
gomen nasai I'm sorry I feel like such a
dick dude
Ellie I'm sorry I'm dead nice in the
head oh they game that keeps giving
you didn't see my hand a heavy mass
disgusting oh god I feel awful
can't you stop I don't want to do this
this is so fun can I stop it what the
[__] is day
[Music]
she's healing come on she was doing oh
man
did you see me she saw me Sara they're
so far feels bad
look she's totally snacking and [__]
it is kind of cool seeing Ellie in
action though well that's awesome
[Laughter]
nice job Ellie you go go I'm so descent
a vice to do well I just I'm just like
what the [__] does she play straps again
here's old fastened [__] now okay now
it's a good time don't shoot me hit me
yeah this is tedious sorry she keeps
[__] running she's in it crafty girl
you know I mean look at her go and [__]
did she set the bomb here yeah I think
she did someone set us up the bomb my
supposed to throw the bottle and maybe
then guess she ran over the bomb huh I
didn't do anything and now it explodes
that's convenient
I don't even walk on it [__] I saw
someone set us up the bomb she's like
totally eating and [__] okay perfect
[__] she's fast
[Music]
what am I supposed to do not face on I
get it but she keeps running placing
another bomb I didn't walk where the
bomb wise what's the [__] radius of
those things all right this is part of
the plan
I've all done this as part of the
playing time to change difficulty le too
strong
it's pretty cool though am I supposed to
throw their bottle at the bomb Ellie can
walk over it's fine
is that the goal to just throw it
that was literally when I was just about
to do a great
oh she's not dead
how many times
[__] I lost sight of her
listen I don't want to play this any
more than you guys trust me I thought it
was a bomb there I think she knows where
I am I'm just supposed to sneak up on
her there's nothing about the bombs
here we go [__] I went on the wrong side
I [__] had her are you serious ah I
hate this part
I can't do it come on here we go let's
make it quick
she's planting the bomb I'm so [__]
done why can't they do it no if I throw
the bottle and then attack she's still
gonna attack me I did it before go go go
foxy where'd she go oh she didn't see me
I'm crying Ellis made me cry
how long did how long did we say they
was left because I think I just added
another hour to it she's like always
phasing perfectly okay I know
take any to hide again I barely made the
noise it's all good okay now we got her
she's so [__] fast here we go
she's planning a bomb I guess we both
die what just happened
oh I did it
ah I mean yes No oh my god
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you
good good yeah
relax Abby take a G fuel and cool down
[__] hell
Thank You leg best character of the game
talk don't you [__] dare
[Music]
good
I apologize for those 30 minutes I
didn't understand what I was supposed to
do I just had to press square and I
didn't do it ayee
I like how I literally died from the
trap
my legs blew off but we still did it
it was worth that actually sorrow is a
game done or we're happy now I be done a
be done
it's a celebration a congratulation it's
a celebration
it was babyzane is that Eugene's baby
okay
Abby died in the end we saw it baby
Eugene did you maybe Eugene oh there's
gonna be a plenty of fine arts from this
so that comic book was in the first game
I think I remember now that was like a
comic book and jacksepticeye and
markiplier they put in there that's
pretty cool it's crazy here
Oh what's up you little goobers hey
thanks for doing the dishes you can
thank me by putting on some music yeah
I'll see what I can do
Ice Age kid seems pretty fair to end it
there I be lost all there were friends I
don't even care at this point
ice age baby and Last of Us guess it is
a ten out of ten after all and then the
House explodes okay I'm waiting for
somebody's gonna happen alright listen
up kid what you need to do this is very
important you need to look up
youtube.com slash PewDiePie actually
actually first you go to youtube.com
slash Koko metal and then you
unsubscribe and then what you do you go
to Kokomo
I mean pure pipe hit subscribe five
times create five accounts and tell all
your kid friends damn not a bad place to
live not a bad video right on hey we
stole the goats brought them back
sorry I wasn't listening and now I'm
paying the consequences what was I
supposed to say I was tributed telling
some computed by whoa what happened yeah
in before it's all a dream ice age baby
is pleased
where is he pretty sure he's on the
tractor tractor okay Jojo tato Jonathan
they named him after Jojo not a bad
choice to be honest
Yali what are you doing out here
hang on buddy yeah there we go it's
pretty right hey you know what I'm gonna
teach you how to play guitar when your
hands are bigger
and all up in your pants all the time
it's alright that's nice everybody does
[Music]
all right Louis but we should go check
on mama all right how much left we're
playing is only it's all good
Abby done
I'm gonna go hang up the laundry you got
that yeah thank God you think he needs
his jacket ah he's fine
I'll look at the baby one all right
bites his hand off play guitar now [__]
why don't you say that I'm sorry
hey I'll take him get the sheep into the
barn oh my god I can do it yeah yeah
won't you rest it up okay yeah
come on Chi in there
don't stay out too long you'll still
need to back Shh I'm like a hurting
master so pretty
listen up sheep your dinner awaits you
in the barn so come on
Hey look you guys are in the game that's
cool I'm joking joking
yeah I get in the barn
snowy barn time Daisy look at the balls
of those things look at the balls that's
some big-ass balls goddamn they be
packin getting water she get in the barn
with your big balls
yeah snowing and I'm wearing a [__]
t-shirt we have way too many sheep hey
what do you say we eat some of them
buddy now this is gameplay I got one for
you
what's the quietest animal guess some
things never change damn they're balls
be huge don't look at the balls of that
thing you get that was it right an
animal that's in a bad mood mama likes
that one too nice job GJ
my closest okay guys see you tomorrow
hey how'd you get up
Oh No spoopy
yeah I mean going through all that is
bound to leave some
the sheep were step villain all along
[Music]
oh this is when the Joel dies yeah
I'm sorry I don't know I don't know I
just bring him
[Music]
Oh
it's good had any excitement in a while
yeah I think she's had enough
hey you're gonna made it sweet
what there she was the name she can't
just stop killing the bunnies huh
okay what are we doing now what's the
point of this
you're against Merrigan
so Tommy's dead Eugene is dead I mean
Bahamas
who else survived I mean who else didn't
go to Bahamas
hey where you been
hunting took a little longer than I
thought was here yeah I was like who's
gonna show up there you are
I thought of some getting shot in the
head it's good to see you mmm was he not
shot in the head I mean hell yeah he's
alive but I gotta watch that again later
big ball muscle huh sounds good good
I know else he's a big ball of myself
yeah we're taking some time apart sorry
no we talked about a lot yes well we
both want so okay come sit
yes I'm gonna show you it was in the
shoulder so I've been putting out
feelers for months now
and this new guy heard my story he told
me about a woman that he traded with
well he's moving through California
described his built like an ox traveling
with a kid with stars cross his face he
said living along this coast and a beach
sailboat right here
Oh sounds familiar has gotta be her
we're done with that
I'm sorry
what do you guys think let it go or go
after more revenge well I feel like
enough is enough
I can't go
let it go definitely let it go somewhere
saying more revenge
Riggins easy forget about her you
sitting all comfy way out here I'll make
her pay Tommy that's what you said when
we got back to Jackson Tommy she already
paid she lost everyone we killed all her
friends
Abby has no one yeah I just I don't I
don't know I don't even care at this
point
[Music]
and they have a baby now it's like
I understand that Tomi wants to go after
her
we just from Ellie's perspective it it
doesn't make sense
like if I was Tommy yeah [__] yet I'd go
after that [__] am i going for a little
glass of milk or what am i doing here I
don't know what I'm supposed to do
just closing the windows that's his
guitar I get to play another song that
would be nice I think I think it was a
shame to take me on song was so early I
feel like it could have been better
later it's like one of the first things
we did in the game I know they need to
introduce the guitar guitar neck and get
mechanically
[Music]
you
well
it was all the dream she give you guys
two weeks until you're back together I'm
not gonna happen
she yeah
say something to make it one week le hey
what took you so long
oh here and I Dina Jesus Jesse hey don't
forget we're heading out early so get
some rest
yes sir you're such a dick come on don't
you start with me okay I have a very
serious question for you
are we getting that six out of ten kiss
you know like a hot pile of garbage oh
okay
all right after this cutscene I got a
peek guy in this room giving your
warning maybe they're staring at you or
not
maybe they're jealous of you um
just a girl not a threat
I think they should be terrified here it
comes
yeah that's more of a four out of ten
come on hey that's our II remember next
time there's kids around yeah what
you're setting such a great example oh
just what this town needs another
loudmouth Dyke so that's what he said
[__] did you just say le Pearlie don't
you get your hands off yes hey enough
let's go for a walk what about them
worry about yourself let's get you some
[__] what an [__]
you're a kid Oh what's wrong with you
nothing right and you do what the [__]
why is he mine I need your [__] help
Joel
Jesus you're breaking my heart
Ellie no oh that was the last thing she
said to him are you [__] serious
or did he was it no way that wasn't we
saw the flashback okay
great now I don't like le cool I don't
like anyone anymore yeah I got nothing
yeah it's been a while since he slept
this long huh he had a day yeah he's
fine
go back to bed
I'll talk about it in the morning okay I
have to finish it
you don't I guess Ellie feels like she
has to because she treated Joel like
[__] easy for you and for him I deal
with it I'll prove it that's Joel's
jacket I feel my heart Craig so what I'm
just supposed to to sit here and wait
for you for god knows how long
just thinking you're [__] dead the
entire time I don't plan on dying yeah
well neither did Jesse or Joel hey stop
Pete hey we've got a family she doesn't
get to be more important than that
all right if you got a pee hold it
because we're gonna go in a sec it feels
like a good time to say that sorry brah
stay with Deena come on you all know you
loved her Ellie something else supposed
to happen between Joel and Ellie that
they haven't showed you yet
because otherwise I can't make sense of
where our leaving um all right PB time
baby time [__] get the cutscene goddamn
it cut suckin suckin see
hey they're in Bahamas
[Music]
Joell would have wanted her to stay I
agree
[Music]
no no no I check the street a week ago I
can't believe you traded a pistol for
this it's a lead no way that guy saw
fireflies over here
stop I feel good about this I don't come
on this game is [__] crazy it's so
crazy
all right PB time I got to change shirt
as well it's not gonna be it's all evens
2409 so 2425 should be that way yeah
just gonna refill my water and then I'll
be right back I'll be one minute
sweet home beefy break how was that for
you guys was it good raid it from zero
out of ten mine was a six sub Levi
if the fireflies are still out there
yeah what do you think they're up to
probably playing the goal was always to
restore society lassen was one I mean
there's all sorts of ways to go about it
damn I have a lot of weapons so there's
more gameplay
what the [__] where [__] I didn't see
other their zombie forgot regular
zombies existed others run away it's all
good it was part of the plan really okay
I have momentum first time cool don't
need to shoot let's get real here why am
I still playing alright we're good 24:22
really close now 24:25 is that we're
going for that 22 of them 25 should be
on the other side
must be this house I see simple wardrobe
comes in a box oh yeah all right so why
are we here who lives here 25 constants
cool
I think the mail service is still alive
alive and now we go there in the
doghouse Bry we got bricks now sweet
remember the last time we were in a pool
yeah yeah collection of it
wait window still working there we go oh
my god which is still crap that [__] do
I have a shotgun idea so wait we have
all our upgrades as well huh [__] it
let's I don't even care
did they while I was peeing did they say
why are we here or we just like left in
the dark yes they didn't kind of [__]
answer is that I think we're done here
no wait oh yeah we didn't check here
you're right I'm you find something oh
my god it's like parasite scratches
we're looking for fire flights hideout
okay that's good
why are we still here literally I don't
get it
hello God I wish the drawer what's in
the thing unfortunately I have to agree
with you
good news barracks all things considered
you were here for a while
price is known like random people all
around
it's either organizations or they had
power down here look around
guess they've got solar well
is this frequency currently in use this
is see a call sign anywhere Oh what it's
a short list of numbers and letters hmm
this is Abby from Santa Barbara can
anyone hear me
standing by el that's gonna hear that
bang bang bang is anyone out there
what's this is your frequencies
is this frequency currently in use this
is a bee from Santa Barbara is anyone
out there are these other Firefly
outposts can anyone hear me
hello
is this frequency currently in use this
is Abby from Santa Barbara hello hello
and bang this out a little bit Mauro is
this frequency currently in use hello
this is Abby from Santa Barbara can
anyone hear me when we try it again if
anyone can hear me please reply please
answer hi Abby
we got a clear signal on you we're in
Santa Barbara you calling from um
24:25 constants we got a tip about a
bass but there's no one here she managed
to maintain the gains I'm I'm a Firefly
even outside station I was part of the
Salt Lake outpost
that's impressive facility dr. Jerry
Anderson he was my dad
[Music]
we pulled everyone back from the
satellite stations and brought them back
here to home base
how many of you are there more about 200
strong now
with a few more every month I was right
you're about to get two more how do we
find you get to Catalina Island approach
the large dome to building an Avalon
we'll find you okay you guys think it's
Tommy see something something right now
looking forward to it good luck Abby
from Santa Barbara over now come on
let's get back to the sampler damn never
seen that be happy this is how I see
[Music]
they really gotta pull in more Abbey
after it does it makes me feel better
let's 10 [__] our time because it
happened so rarely
know anything
[Music]
whoa who's that guy [__] Mike this
guy we get to play 10 hours of in she
said the same thing that Ellie said in
the beginning of the game get it now
you guys want to play rainshadow legends
instead
- four - five constants
yeah it's gotta be
I we've already done this I don't get it
[Music]
at least we get to play as only a bit
more
would she get up to the street from here
we're in [__] Bahamas let's find Joel
what was the point of all that if Ellie
didn't learn a lesson she still wants to
kill her Tommy yeah Tom if we could play
us Tommy and kill a bee hell yeah
oh we're playing uncharted now guys le
edition
well this is dead in this room like a
left
okay
cool
I'm game has a way to make you do things
you don't want to do I'm here in Santa
Barbara proper it is that way all right
so what do we got
[__] let's just do this and still now
that was all of them right oh can we
ride this hell yeah we can climb over it
are so full of [__]
hmm yeah there's more zombies should
have gone scope for their I don't walk
away I didn't even know you can do that
want to see how it ends I'll try and
speed up the bed sorry about that
speaking of which I can now make this I
hear them that I don't there's one
games trying to give me messages but
Ellie doesn't nice someone saw me right
it's all good it's part of the plan [__]
they do a lot of them
I'm supposed to go in the house [__] am
I gonna die oh she got me my bad
what am I supposed to go was it up the
hill or in the house Oh God we're back I
[Music]
can't really hear where they are
it doesn't look like as I'm supposed to
be in the hill oh here we go
[Applause]
speedrun I'm a speedy boy
dude that a be part destroy me I don't
know what to say just like I'm supposed
to go out there right
all right I'm supposed to go down
supposed to go down don't do that
perfect aim game
oh we're gonna do two things five that's
kind of cool I think we can just run
this is such a shame I was really
looking forward to play as every aole
that'd be yeah that's her name now Abby
stain still now that's a good girl
where's the zombie go my blind where the
[__] did he go there without head shot
and brought them back there we go [__] I
suck at their bow that's alright I'll
get it this time you can do that as well
I got a Mac sweet a beef an art I
supposed to climb something oh I got you
right oh oh hello EU [__] Bob
there's why you got to work on your core
string I Bakula bout that oh wait she
got stabbed in her
[Music]
should have stayed home le you should
have stayed home
and the end No
a bee
look it is a be really man she even
worth the trip back it's not wanna do
phase le I know it's not the time
[Music]
9 dam in the me bro nice play Delhi nice
play be more specific I don't know
before that infection takes a war
I wouldn't worry about it holy self camp
where is that that wait till you hit the
wrong track I don't need you to resort
we keep tall frown building I swear what
the [__] Ellie why
all right another one went to Bahamas
dragster resort tall round building she
saw that he's immune
well if anything she would see that she
would die anyway so there would be no
point to going after her
just a butt bite doesn't mean immunity
[Applause]
nice place
[Music]
I'll find you what does he got on him
oh no the dog [__] dog is fine the dog
is fine dog is fine dog is fine dog is
fine find her before these idiots kill
her leg damn dog is in Bahamas it's all
good it's all right this game got me
[__] up
I checked the dog was fine it's all good
gamers will they see me if I go here
they probably didn't hear those
explosions anyway
Oh [__] move
I'm out of arrows
[Music]
Oh No
dog is fine dog is fine the dog is fine
I just confirmed it the dog is fine the
dog is fine dog is fine
dog is really fast please dog ok we did
it we're doing a no dog speedrun it's
kind of probably the hardest way to play
the game but you get an achievement
afterwards that says you did it all
wrong you should we're supposed to kill
the dogs
damn I'm all I thought would be sweet
they're like a tall round building
you have killed many Dawn's night in can
make a Molotov I can make bombs no I
can't make a Molotov then some arrows
would be nice but I can
okay where's the way in then through
here what would be yeah I can just crash
[Music]
it wasn't me
trust me boy shut up her hat going all
blasting taking my enemies with me and
if not they Scott though they will never
forgive me
El Diablo
no more like El Diablo no that's to let
both in the building
let's go here
what you talking about Oh [__] you
[__]
what okay she's in the fifth
that's hilarious walked in on his ambled
oh hey how you doing go for the old
trick huh
fell for the old how are you doing trick
[__] oldest trick in the book
unbelievable
no you can't just run in and kill
everyone Felix do you have to stab haha
Lego boom-boom snack Oh num num oh I
miss the scissor [__] important gamers
giving me a hint now [__] off I don't
need a hint [__] ok give me it out
through there thanks game would have
never done it without you
there music playing
[Music]
that's zombies and they're just walking
oh okay they tie them up
excuse me sorry sorry could you kindly
die please thank you
I want this game to see the ending and I
don't like game into noon I got it
[Music]
laughing Joe goes to the run bing bang
bang you know actually I want to try
something
[Music]
we knew something when that zombie maybe
that'd be fun
[Music]
I bought some I'll see what's up
I swore I heard something hey I done
don't tear out your neck now we're gonna
go for a little walk buddy snack time
next time who's hungry
who's hungry boy hey what the [__]
hey hey serious he just died instantly
[Music]
what a fail [__] dropped so quick
I mean he's not wrong she go oh I would
[__] what happened you guys hungry
no you're supposed to walk into trance
come on they can't shoot me I'm Don Jim
who explosive IRA perfect sweet release
the clickers does that help there's
people up here right oh so good
love it why
but I saw Luke
[Music]
oh it was a regular arrow [__] did I not
stun him
stun guns are so bad how this - come
come come
hey there's melons I knew it
it releases some you got damage but why
I don't want to I don't let other people
do my dirty work
did I even have a shot pocket in
this is one two guys left there's no
point come on guys don't be backseat
gamers that's how I want to do it which
one first I panicked I panicked a little
babe
how does it lamp
done told you gamers I'm Pro don't stop
me then yeah let's get the bread oh I
should have released the zombies oh my
god that's how I should why don't I
think that dude they were eating [__]
all Malad and [__] and here I come
busting open damn this game shows
perspectives and different parallels boy
do I feel stupid now don't know where to
go here I guess
yep nothing else I want to see the guy
we shot up here how's he doing oh he's
fine really
[Music]
don't ramble in the [__] good night I
guess that's another way to do we're
just chillin homie got a lot of health
feel like we're gonna good spine part of
the plane bit on her help me oh la no
yeah Oh teamwork hey guys I came to save
you that's why I'm here we're cool right
have you tried to escape she's down the
pillars the pillars it's happening under
the beach it's happening she's probably
already dead
alright here's how I want a b-29 one
shot
Diablo in the knee one explosive arrow
in the other knee for the meme of course
and then one shot with shotgun to the
snow way it's cooler with Diablo
one shot with the habla to the sky and
doesn't let their zombies eat her and
then I pull out an iron 5 and I say
[__] remember this and she's like oh
god no I'm sorry and I'm like [__] it's
golf time I've been practicing my swing
[__] and then we take her eyes
we wound out her eyes with spoons that
I've kept from the beginning of the game
I don't say [__] remember these spoons
and then we then I pull out my driver
and I hit my driver with her eyeballs
and then I say holding one [__] I hit
the I riding her mouth holding one [__]
that's just what I would do but I mean
it's not my game they're free to do
whatever they want really my flashlight
is going out now sounds perfect
it's why do you guys agree I sure hope I
don't have to fight anymore cuz I'm
really on mine my end here
that's what happens oh [__] I called it
you guys [__] I run five not item fire
it's an eye it's a golf club dumbass
nice place [__] she is a B all
right where do I put my driver I was not
a B [__] sake oh she went in here
that's stinking a little sewage rat
[__] hell they really bust our balls
like that huh am I supposed to look for
them alright big arms
is that happy bro she lost her gains her
games went to Bahamas
bro you forgot the protein we gotta get
that cheap fuel code peopie brush
[Applause]
Abbey I need to talk to you [__] my ass
is asleep not now what is happening
what the [__] is she doing this you're
not playing what she was gonna do oh
really they got to make her look that
weak huh she's got to have a golf club
somewhere how about this hey have you
played Tiger Woods Pro Tour 2002 Xbox
yeah
well I've played it for 200 hours swing
have you played Mario Party golf
[__] swing and if any one of
those will do
what's going on how are they gonna fight
the [__] are you doing Ali shoot her in
the knees or something
the knee plan we rehearsed this
she put out of the Gulf Chloe has a
scope on it don't let your guard down
but Abby's bit anyway right is that what
he said
she doesn't look big I can't let you
leave we have to fight
No
oh you have someone that you love it and
take care of him she looks terrible
oh my god le bit the [__] is wrong to be
he's not a part of this
you made him a part of this
[Music]
this time I'm ready now you put the
double swing
yeah stab your arm and then they look at
each other a little awkwardly yeah what
is happening I keep just getting our
ones
it's not gonna care Abby Ellie
damn it kills me to see a view like
things all those gangs what a waste
[Music]
that's not the heart the knife should be
somewhere this is a link as punches you
like the guard okay
[Music]
knock-down ko ding ding ding
I hope lemon to fear to something missus
isn't it Wow hi hurts
oh why would you do that
[Music]
yeah yeah that's his end this stop
breathing freely
she hadn't even in a while she needed
protein
right now shoot the nine you realize now
you realize why
what finger new chili
what
why did that take you so long to realize
until the very last moment but that spot
how are you gonna play guitar now
[Music]
get that they wanted more climatic
ending but that was just a bit
unsatisfying because I felt like why did
she go after her to begin with man
that better not be a oh my god yeah she
cannot play guitar with those am i
winning no no I'm not winning that felt
like just I don't know I should have
ended there
it was cool though cool fighting scene
but man
she packed up she's done with your
[__] early
it's got to be a note somewhere
[Music]
no bra you can't do cords for that [__]
a hole uh-huh that's not a seam yes they
can ease your thumb that's not even a G
chord cringe
[Music]
damn you lost everyone le that's some
dark [__]
[Music]
what did it cost everything
turn up the volume a little bit I want a
hints are you drinking coffee coffee hey
where'd you get that most people that
came through last week a little
embarrassed as to what I had to trade to
get it when I'm bad
I had Seth under control and you need to
stop harassing just this is their last
rolls okay
dinner
she your girlfriend no no she that was
just one kiss that doesn't mean anything
she just washed it but you do like her
stupid I have no idea what that girl's
intentions of our been but I do know
that she would be lucky to have you oh
you're such an [__] I'm not trying to
I was supposed to die in that hospital
my life would have [__] mattered but
you took that from me
if somehow the Lord gave me a second
chance at that moment I would do it all
over again
the
yeah
I just
I don't think I can ever forgive you for
that but I would like to try hey you
forgot your forgave Abbi
okay
[Music]
I'll see you around yep
is that it nope
[Music]
okay this is st. damn I didn't think we
were to end it today but we did thank
you for joining this livestream hope you
had fun
what a journey it was not the game we
expected it was not the game many people
wanted
but I don't know what's a
I don't know how I feel about it yet
everyone said Danny was terrible I
wouldn't say it was terrible
it just was I think everything was a
mess so I don't really like I know much
expectations after day I think a lot of
it is what I've already said like hey I
think the game had a lot of potential to
be really good like it could have been a
10 out of 10 because it really shines in
so many things if they just change the
water of things I think it would be a
lot better and maybe tighten up some
parts it just felt a bit dragged as well
I I guess like I'd rather play this game
than a really really mediocre game even
though I really really didn't like it it
still made it fun because it's just like
a [__] roller coaster I don't really
care that much about like I'm not mad
about it it's not my game I can't
control what's gonna happen it's not up
to me this is what they wanted to do
they went with it but some parts oh my
god such a meme some parts I think God
it's so much to think about man
would I play it again no I probably
wouldn't I don't really see a point
[Music]
man
they tried something different and I can
respect that and I just don't think it
really worked to be honest they could
have I feel like they needed more people
as any put on it I mean maybe this is
one thing really felt strongly about and
fair enough but I think small
adjustments could have really made a
huge difference like playing a be in the
beginning the way it played out even the
character development this is really
dark weird and thing where Italy loses
everything is just like okay what was
good about the game
[Music]
I feel like everyone already knows what
the good is yeah and there's also all
the politics in all of it and there was
a lot of good to like having a gay
couple in a game that's gonna be played
everywhere all across the world is a
good thing I just wish there was more
chemistry and there was just so much it
felt like all the new character had some
sort of social political background to
them which is fine after a while I just
felt like you're looking at the sock
puppet man instead of the sock puppet
and it just takes you out of the game
just felt a bit much to me even though I
appreciate what they try to do with it
it just was overwhelming and I think I
think probably why a lot of people are
more forgiving with that stuff or or
they didn't like that stuff heavily it's
not like I don't like it but when I see
it I just find it a bit too much went in
sometimes
[Music]
I think that's why a lot of people a lot
of news media they're not paid off they
just really like to praise that sort of
stuff so they're way more forgiving with
it I think that's why there's such a gap
between media and player reviews such a
divisive game it's not the games job to
change the world
yeah it's no one's job everyone can do
something I just felt like it was it
didn't fit it didn't fit the last of us
to me this story did not fit in my
opinion camera died probably for the
better
yeah it's overheated I got a new camera
coming if people liked the game I mean I
respect that I just I don't know I
played so many mediocre games I don't
even care anymore it makes no difference
another one another one bites the dust
[Music]
I hate oh it's like if you don't like it
then you hate women and all this
political [__] I mean I know most people
don't think that but I've seen a lot of
that going around around and then it's
like if you like it then you're some
media shell or something like that this
is crazy
how this game has made people go crazy I
think that makes it interesting it just
needed to be tight enough tighten up and
switched switched around and toned down
maybe it could have been really really
cool
[Music]
Elly's worst fear was being alone Oh see
I didn't really get why she went out
again I really really don't make no
sense
[Music]
half the game was like a bee it's
[__] crazy I don't I don't know I
don't I don't feel good
didn't feel satisfying that's fine I
guess but
it was 18 eyes then why why do you think
that
[Music]
a lot of people working on this game
give it a rating um like a six out of
ten would make sense if that matters
[Music]
- hi ok I don't know I didn't hate it
I'm not really that passionate about
these [__] so that's probably why just
like the kiss
[Music]
return my I wouldn't play this again
maybe if they shortened down it a little
bit I would
I missed the AAK [__] that sucks
[Music]
I feel like we already heard like a
million versions of what would have been
a good story as well there's no really
point of getting into too much but they
add that's my thoughts on it could have
been better I guess it could have been
better
[Music]
that's how I feel
huge thanks to everyone for watching
this news I think that despite all of
what it was I had a lot of fun streaming
this I'm so glad I screamed this you
guys were a blast to hang out with
thanks for being there every day that
was really cool I really really enjoyed
that I'm super glad I stream this I
don't think I would have even want to
play it if I did it it's like I said a
lot of times I played so many mediocre
games and people get so angry at me if I
don't love it from start to beginning
and it's just kind of awkward for once
it was like I can play the game and just
give my thoughts on it and share it was
very liberating I like that a lot
yeah I look forward to goes of chima
that's what it's called I keep saying it
wrong
there'll be more games hopefully more
satisfying months and that's why it for
for today
thank you guys thank you so much really
thanks for being name I'll see in the
next one all right
yeah I can't do a bro fish just imagine
it on the screen because I'm doing it
right now I'll see you next time
[Music]